[Music]
pump
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for having us
this chicken is
yeah y'all are delicious anytime and
what does daddy get for all his hard
work the big piece of chicken
[Laughter]
always gets a laugh from right now chris
rock
i haven't seen it
oh my gosh i can't believe you haven't
seen that honey yeah i love chris brock
he's so funny
did you really see it ricky especially
since you're a big comedy fan
i don't think so
why not
well i'm a racist so
oh
so
you think black people are inferior
right
and that'd be because of their skin
color
so it's not um
cultural cultural no not at all
i don't make this dinner all about me uh
you guys have any plans for halloween um
yeah we'll we'll go to jeff's parents
with the kids i'm sorry i feel like i
need to say something no really
it's fine
it's not okay jen ricky
if you really feel that way about
the blacks
i'm i just don't feel like i can be in
this relationship anymore
wait so you didn't know i was a racist
of course not what you didn't notice how
i don't have any black friends that i
don't listen to rap music you never
notice my oversized exclusively white
dog
remember that time i said i wanted tyler
perry to get waterboarded
i thought you just hated madea oh you
mean big mama's house no medea okay so
the movie where the young black guy
dresses up like a spunky old black woman
yes medea
um i think it's fair to say that i'm
i'm pretty i'm pretty uncomfortable i
think you'd probably go home oh jeff
honey let's all just take a deep breath
and try and enjoy our dinner
i totally agree
do you
this pineapple fried quinoa is fantastic
oh uh
jeff and i just got around to seeing the
new oceans movie um ocean's eight yeah i
think it was yeah have you all seen it i
loved it
really
of course i'm not a sexist
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
that's called as as little of that as i
can actually uh bring in because uh that
is piping hot
it's supposed to be that is absolutely
piping hot and uh are we are we good on
sound here yeah i'm sounding awful and
you're sounding clear as belle ah you
sound fantastic all right it could just
be my head not as good as me but you
know close all right okay well look uh
just so you know really quickly dave
lando's not here he's uh yeah he's back
on the wagon we put out an amber off the
wagon i don't know which i don't know
what the expression is can you guys let
me know early on this is just i want you
guys to to comment below and let me know
if it's on the wagon off the wagon
because if you're on the wagon
the point is he's a drunk no uh we have
no idea where he is he might be on his
way in later but uh don't worry we have
a lot to discuss today namely uh we're
going to be talking about russia and the
ukraine and i know before your eyes
glaze over mine did too it matters it
does matter but that's not how you get
people interested oh there were also
there will be russian breasts
look if they can do it in their own news
certainly we can talk yes you can order
wife from amazon prime
and become president so uh we'll be
talking about russian ukraine just
really quickly if we get booted because
you never know what's going to happen
with the youtube when you're discussing
russia china covet anything uh you can
watch us on rumble or on mug club of
course there's a full extra hour of show
on mug club it's monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern 10 a.m eastern and this
thursday we have a super video on
wikipedia yeah we've run some tests we
feel confident now and letting you know
that it's far worse than you imagined
uh so that's gonna be fun on thursday i
love it okay big big video that took a
lot of work from a lot of people here
first question though before we move on
and talk about russia and ukraine and we
actually will have some people in here
to argue about it
um a lot of different opinions in the
office just to be clear so this
episode this show's going to be a little
bit different we're going to have
differing point of points of view you
know the patent point of view yeah of we
uh defeated the wrong enemy should have
defeated the nazis but also the russians
and then uh we'll have uh differing
points of view or we shouldn't do
anything we should let uh ukraine fend
for themselves so you know what it's a
hodgepodge i like it it's a potluck of
geopolitical mystery but my question to
you is it was i think last week we asked
do you think so now it's uh it's the uh
updated version when do you think russia
is going to be invading the ukraine
can we get an over under on tuesday
after biden's speech
send some people over to to draftkings
yeah yeah to foreign policy warhawk
what's the line
um gosh this is going to be a weird
weird you thought 2020 number one
thought thank god 2020 is over remember
the 2021 new year's like thank god 2020
is over oh because you think the date
changes
your rights coming back and now we're in
2022 and now oh my gosh outside of uh
you know the pandemic covet there's an
actual conflict that could be
significant that you may have to worry
about now just add that to your plate
this is going to be a nutty week uh here
to talk about it with me of course he
knows his foreign policy is gerald hey
how are you i am well sir how are you
i'm okay yeah yeah i had a busy weekend
yeah i imagine yeah a little lots of
stuff going on a lot lots of stuff going
on you got little rugrats rug rats yeah
one of them tested positive for the
covid one contested negative so it's
like you got to keep them apart
i don't i don't think you say the cove
that's like saying the face i put my
spin on it
and uh we don't have dave here but we
actually do have he works here as a
researcher as a producer uh his name is
well you know what he's gingersnap to us
because his hair is fiery right
gingersnap how are you sir i'm fantastic
and appreciate the love with the
nickname yes let me let everyone see
your hair let everyone see your hair he
asked where he has to wear his burger
king kids club
look at this oh for crying out loud
there are a few perverts who are going
to love that you can put your head back
i guess it's off it's off
i think the thing is with redheads
they're like with at least with guys
brunettes blondes you know bear girls
smaller girls it's a preference redheads
it's a fetish it is right it's a fetish
stephen can you guess where we imported
him from
i would well i know you know what people
won't be able to strangely yeah
strangely enough yes tell them where you
came from gingersnap i came fresh off
the boat from south korea oh my gosh in
south korea they must have not welcomed
him there at all i stood out a little
bit did you eat canine
oh my word did he say yes he didn't say
no
it's a horrible start oh my gosh
we have two canine eating fools in this
place yes and dave's let us know when
dave comes in so we can admonish david
we will yeah yeah they're going to let
us know when he's ready to rock and roll
so before we move on to russia and the
updates here uh and uh former vice
president joe biden in his ineptitude uh
gosh i just see lizzo in the show map
and i was told not to watch this
have you seen this gingersnap i have
it's not amazing he keeps looking down
at his notes he's nervous he's like a
bird dog right now he's like
it's okay
just relax just be yourself ginger snap
same thing just be yourself people will
like you they won't like
himself he needs to fake it
lizzo apparently overcooked her pizza
let's watch
so i'm sitting here str
what the [ __ ]
so i'm sitting here stressed out
no that's your actual size feelings and
i can't even
eat my feelings right i overcooked my
pizza look at
this not supposed to do it
you still don't eat it though
yes
well i was hoping for a zag but
yeah well you know what she has to dip
her pizza in ranch because pizza needs
ranch it does pizza gets so dry
there's just not enough already on pizza
pizza's just a layering mechanism it is
she's going to she just says she's
eating her feelings she is if you're
gonna eat your feeling she needs her
pizza oven stapled
she had a diet coke right next to it
though so she's totally fine is there a
kitchen band procedure
it's called a lock yeah it's called a
lock it's called a padlock lock the
doors
to anything that contains food throw
away your phone cause you can order
ubereats crying out loud i just you know
this here's the thing yeah we get it
okay
but have the self-awareness to not
upload you discussing eating your
feelings and dipping pizza in ranch and
at the very least every single video
like that should end with by the way
this is really unhealthy and i'm gonna
die soon
there should be a surgeon general's
warning on everything yes there should
be producers exactly it's like a pack of
cigarettes you have a lung it should
just be like the the dinner plate
nipples yeah
of what happens when you gain that much
weight on every single lizzo cd yeah
absolutely be careful you could end up
like this as opposed to explicit content
tip or gore get dinner plate nipples
and rags on sticks and put it on every
single lizzo cd
oh my gosh did we lose power are we gone
are we are we gone off the stream or is
the stream still going on well i don't
know i have no idea it feels like we
lost powerpoint we did lose power looks
like to the entire building uh we should
be on well yeah oh i think our backup
generator may still be going you may not
be able to see us but you might be able
to hear us so the blaze can hear us
it seems can youtube hear us i don't
know we're finding out right now let's
have someone come in as soon as you uh
it looks like youtube's still up there
i'm still up huh
up up up hours back
look at that all right hold on a second
guys we're gonna just see if we're still
oh no what is going on here oh what are
we saying it's lizzo she's attacking me
okay it looks like we're back up oh my
gosh on rumble and we're still up on
youtube still up we are still on youtube
so that whole thing was on youtube yeah
did they hear my racial tirade well like
i said they didn't hear me call they
didn't hear me call uh uh call and leave
those racist voicemails did they while
we were i mean i did it it was a very
short amount of time but what are you
mel gibson i have short windows of free
time so i make best use of it
you multitask you have to multitask yeah
i think they were coming in to say that
we're we're back up okay did it cancel
the stream on youtube hey guys guys
everyone comment below just this is a
good good chance comment below do you
guys just see that dark and did you see
yeah it actually happened you didn't see
ginger snap servicing himself furiously
did you it was quick it was quick no no
he's trying to get in his steps if you
move your watch yes
i gotta get a thousand steps in today
yeah in addition to what it doesn't know
what to do with the heart rate
variability
so uh hold on i want to make sure uh
okay all is well still all right okay so
uh we can move on there from liverpool
you just struck our studio with a
missile and they didn't know i have no
idea what even just happened that was
the weirdest thing there may have been
construction or something that hit power
so we do have a backup generator that
keeps the stream going yeah yeah yeah it
keeps all the like essentials going
other than lights other than lights
one would imagine other than people
being able to see us on a video on a
video program you know there's a fair
point there yeah we'll have to we'll
have to look at that list again just
give me like you know i just have at
least like one light so i can do the
earnest scared stupid bit well i'll just
give you a flashlight for the desk right
okay there you go what's going on there
tim the tool man what do you need he's
just
getting everything reset okay for us
yeah look yeah this is what happens when
we're live do you realize how few people
do live programs like this for this
reason right do you have any ideas
harder than that no no no no we're
better than them no stephen colbert
doesn't trust himself
cut cut
needles the needles need to look more um
buoyant yeah you know i uh we need
better needles pfizer is paying for top
needle placement
and i'll be damned if we don't give it
to them we have to have good needle
representation okay yes we need equal
needle representation and needle
exchanges all right this is as good a
time as anything to just let you know
but before we move on while we get our
clips back in the tricaster everything
uh follow me on instagram here uh louder
with crowder because someone's sitting
on stephen crowd i believe and uh we'll
be taking your mug club check here later
on we'll have like another full hour
show yeah this is a wonderful start to
the show we we our first clip is lizzo
eating pizza fantastic work guys
and then everything goes dark
people thought they were people thought
they were tuning in to rae's podcast are
you able to pull up cnn or we did we
lose it completely can he uh that tv
just isn't the tv's not coming back on
but i have it on my monitor can you pull
it up
florida house committee passes don't say
gay bill
what the heck just so you guys know i'm
flying you can't fly in the dark here i
promise i'm not lying to you i don't
even know if we can bring it up
that's okay it's okay it's not a big
deal i was just saying that that that's
kind of that's if you so we can't bring
up cnn right now now well something's
got to be reset we uh we can't do it at
this moment i mean we can't make fun of
cnn for like a whole hour and a half i
don't know what just i know what that
means for second half second half of the
show
go go do it live
we have a clip of cnn we'll do it live
hammering yeah all right uh so we do
have a clip here from cnn from before uh
this is great by the way for gingersnap
his first time in here he's just sitting
over there oh god the odor is emanating
from that end of the studio right now
it would have lines did you have a biden
you all right there i'm doing good i'm
just trying not to you know just
overstep my bounds
don't worry you won't over stuff your
bones you're a friendly south korean
white guy
okay this was on uh this morning on cnn
so you know barry weiss was on uh bill
maher yeah and barry weiss used to work
with i believe the new york times and
has had sutter sort of an awakening not
really conservative but uh i guess you
would call her classical liberal and she
made some totally reasonable reasonable
points on bill maher which of course was
trending all over yeah all over this
weekend uh because people were furious
where she was implying that of course
with covet they don't really have the
science at this point they're a negative
like i've always said look here's the
thing with covet no one is saying that
covet isn't real no one is saying that
coba doesn't suck for some people who
get it
with everything in life you have to
weigh the risks and rewards the pros and
cons in this case your basic civil civil
liberties and freedoms versus
omicron which at this point you know for
most people is a cough
uh you don't even
it's actually not even a cough it's it's
uh nasal stuff right it's like a one to
two day
hold basically i had it symptom-wise i'm
not saying you should you know downplay
i had it and i felt like uh you know tom
hanks at the end of philadelphia um so
you know but i got it i got it worse
ready to run a marathon it's also the
aids the aids was really it was more of
a comorbidity yeah yeah i don't i think
that is the morbidity so uh this morning
though on cnn they brought on a doctor
to uh issue counterpoints to barry
weiss's points dr reiner uh from george
washington university and this is the
beauty of you know when these people uh
first off we talked about these comedy
shows they don't do it live okay well
that's wonderful because they can edit
anything to look favorable but then also
on places like that's redundant but then
also i apologize it's the darkness it's
gotten to my brain
it's crap also on cnn or these programs
there's a beauty in uh never being
accountable where you can bring on
people simply to straw man your
opponents because they don't bring barry
weiss on in my opinion if you are
commenting on what barry weiss said on
bill maher specifically right and you
are cnn to do your job and be a
journalist you should have barry weiss
on instead they show a brief clip and
then they bring a doctor on to address
the points that she never made here's
the most trusted name in news i'm done
with kovitz i'm done it's like i i went
so hard on kovid i yeah i remember read
the pringles cans that i bought at the
grocery store stripped my clothes off
because i thought kovit would be on my
clothes like i did it all and then we
were told you get the vaccine that was
my you get the vaccine and you get back
to normal
and
we haven't gotten back to normal and
it's ridiculous at this point we have
this is going to be remembered by the
younger generation as a catastrophic
moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80 i
think minority students has just
announced indefinite virtual schooling
also known as in the past two years
we've seen among young girls a 51
increase in self-harm people are killing
themselves they're anxious they are
depressed they are lonely
that is why we need to end it she uh you
know ranted about how inconvenienced she
has been
by this pandemic and how it's not real
anymore well i'll tell you that for the
10 000 americans who died last week and
for their families yeah it was damn real
and for the people who you know
struggled to keep them alive and for the
thousands and thousands of health care
workers who have been doing this
non-stop for two years her behavior was
childish and and selfish ah okay so you
notice what she said she said look we do
have record number of of teenage
specifically teenage girls they're
self-harm and of course if you look into
those statistics all references
available at lightercredit.com we have
them below as well we've done several
episodes on this there's been an
increase in substance abuse there's been
an increase in hospitalization
alcoholism right suicides way up and he
says i think she's being childish
because she's just talking about how
she's been inconvenienced she didn't
discuss herself being inconvenienced at
all no it was all about how other people
are being destroyed by this specifically
the people that we say we sacrifice
everything for our children right right
now we're sacrificing them right to make
ourselves feel better yeah that's it
right why can schools be closed in one
place and open in another place we all
deal with the same issues we all have
coveted spikes we have omicron that's
kind of running around the country it's
fear that's all that's the only no but
in in flint they should stay home from
school uh and uh drink the tap water yes
get as much of that tap water as
possible
also this is silly political correctness
is when we're talking about language
which is like in flint where it's 80
because you can't just say black
you can't say brown 80 percent minority
imagine if you read a poll
well
a minority of americans believe that joe
but disapprove of joe biden's job on the
economy what's that minority 80 i should
note that the 80 is black
80 percent is not a minority buddies why
do we still say this minorities they're
minorities it's 80 minority not in flint
that would be called a majority sir in
flint you know who's a minority
ginger snap
ginger snap gets caught on the wrong
block no nay on the right block and he's
not living through the day i heard
there's a big swiss population there i
might finish oh yes yes there's a big
swiss population the knives and stuff
yeah they can just remain neutral of
course
all right moving on here to uh um
former vice president joe biden before
we go into this situation with russia
we're gonna have a round table that's
gonna yeah because there are differing
points of view and it's a boring topic
and uh the truth is
it's boring until it's not it's boring
until it's not you know i was very
passionate about the taiwan situation in
china because i understand exactly how
it affects the united states i
understand exactly how it affects all of
us on a global scale i understand that
china is on the move and what they want
to accomplish with russia it's a little
bit harder to be concerned because we
see um a sort of disenchanted sort of
disenfranchised you know former ussr and
people they're not really a threat well
the whole point is they're trying to
build to being a threat and ukraine is
one of those first steps
uh so a lot of people find it
uninteresting what are you guys doing
what are you guys gossiping about over
there is there something wrong with your
class if something is going on you guys
have to let me know
we apparently spelled the russia wrong
in the title so
wow
russia spelled wrong did we i have to
sit in close proximity to a ginger and i
don't know if that [ __ ] rubs off or and
then we lose power and he crapped
himself yes so dave when dave does come
in he's got a surprise in the chair
i hope you had one a hell of a piss
david
um so before we get to russia though joe
biden of course you know he's always
shown a bulldog-like toughness uh toward
putin um like when he said this last
year so you know vladimir putin you
think he's a killer
mm-hmm i do so what price must he pay
the price he's gonna pay well you'll see
shortly
do you mean what he said
oh if you sit on my lap today i guess a
toy is the price you'll pay
name that reference
if putin sits on my left knee don't be
stingy be prepared to pay mickey rooney
you can't give it away mickey that's not
the name of the movie that's an actor i
know but that's like a hint okay all
right all right i shouldn't have given
you guys a hint just ignore mickey
rooney
strike it from the record can we do that
oh no wait we're live as you well know
today so uh what about when he tweeted
this in february 2020 a good year as we
call it
vladimir putin doesn't want me to be
president
he doesn't want me to be our nominee if
you're wondering why it's because i'm
the only person in this field who's ever
gone toe-to-toe to him with him first
off um
what what did you ballroom dance with
him i don't understand well done toe to
toe with putin what does that even
you've never gone toe to toe with
anybody yeah homer a skinny fat butter
soft biotch who has pushed pencils for
your entire life and tries to act like
you're the tough guy who's going to
fight someone behind the bike racks this
is the stuff that he always says he
talks about exists when barack obama
said
everybody knows you you don't mess with
joe no you know it's very clear you're
saying that because that's that's
precisely what you do with joe you're
starting to build them up there's no no
i'll tell them there's nothing to do
with joe biden yeah if not mess with him
well by the way i had i do have a
follow-up question to that he said he
went toe-to-toe with putin yes how did
that go for him
in the obama administration yeah well if
he means that we're talking about what
happened with the ukraine back then um
he was bent over i think i think ukraine
would rather he had not yes they
probably would have called for somebody
else to be their champion right yeah
it's like joe biden walks out and they
lose part of their country and it's like
wait what just happened yeah i know like
an entire pe who did this to us hey it's
me
what joe
i never come back here again we do have
fantastic news dave has been found okay
and we so dave we we are ready for you
to to enter the studio sir come on in
come on in we held him out for a few
minutes for lashes and some other stuff
so is he not actually coming in well
he's supposed to be coming in oh well
good so at least he's on cue now
i mean i i just woke up in a puddle his
own filthy he can come in whenever he's
ready and will admonish the hell out of
him so we are going to before dave comes
in here or whenever he comes in uh we're
going to get to the top four ways that
the united states actually
has sort of been the catalyst and
created the ukraine crisis so it's time
that's why uh gingersnap is here who
works usually in the back room for an
underlying argument
well look who decided to show a little
protest
um
apologize a little late
uh we were protesting and what were you
protesting dave
dicks oh
yeah yeah the d word yeah we've all had
enough of that yeah it was a me too
thing and i'm like nah it's bad right
yes and uh yeah this is well luckily
these are my pajamas i wake up
um it helps the head rest you wear it on
a plane too so you can sleep it is yes
it's an entire body suit for it's also
to keep him from rolling over while he
sleeps it is that's a danger it is a
cpap uh so i apologize i i got uh i
slept in a bit yeah what happened did
you feel arrested and went to a protest
ah i cried everyone admonish him in the
comment section
i'm gonna take off his pillow all right
and you can put on your there you go we
got lane all right oh sorry guys
so what happened your flight got was
late super late yeah uh meatloaf was my
alarm and it didn't go off
[Laughter]
his name was robert paulson dave i'm
sorry robert paulson
no he actually wasn't that was the guy
with the breasts
well i guess
anyway uh no i got a new iphone
ah uh
that uh i was requested to get for the
show
and that's right i set the alarm you
just blamed three different things i
know yeah you blamed meatloaf
he blamed uh tim cook yeah and then
blamed me well because i'm the one who's
paying for the iphone
well you know what's funny that's that's
why this morning when i sent him a text
and it said dave doesn't have
notifications turned on i was like oh
crap oh no but i thought i did but i but
i had the do not disturb with the alarm
yeah and the alarm was turned on it just
didn't go off can i tell you one thing
yeah i don't buy it
my dog that's like the only thing that
always works okay look guys i took uh uh
a 17 ambien for the first time i've
never taken it and i woke up on
somebody's lawn in a vagina suit and
there's a homeless man that makes sense
so by the way if you guys out there see
gopro footage of a martin lawrence like
bender with dave yes it's true i was
waving a gun in traffic yelling there
they gonna get me yeah also just for the
record even though he may say in the
video he is not in fact jesus christ
dave correct the record i am not jesus
christ i'd like to be admonished twice
yes although not jesus christ i did get
three followers
three admonishes
all right i uh i'm not good at
technology no i thought be it
all right now we're glad to have you
with us dave okay we're talking about
russia we're talking about the ukraine
international politics so it's right up
your alley cool i slept in more yes
well you might get the chance here
easy come up
it was a total accident no no and
actually lane and gerald got into a
heated ginger snap here got into a
heated argument with gerald in the back
room uh fisticuffs went flying and so he
said you know what let's just bring this
unadmitted so yeah he did well he just
started submit even though he didn't hit
him well that's true he was he was
pulling his best impression of a
frenchman in war yeah well you look more
french than south korea you don't look
south korea at all yeah he's got the
cheekbones and everything else are you
part south korean he was in south korea
that's where he came from
it's 20 22. i don't know who's got how
many mothers i
it's very difficult to track
here's here's the worst part if i was in
university right now and you answered
that way we would all have to go well
that's what we all did we kind of paused
for a second like
you have two okay what
i forgot to check my time my privilege
check a lot of things yeah it's a lot of
those yeah i was visiting my two dad's
grave yeah and uh that's why i was late
yeah well that makes sense oh yeah
forgot to check in your case you forgot
to check your pigment you are positively
translucent you're like one of those
fish that lives at the bottom of the
ocean that never sees sunlight yeah i
tried to hit the tanning bed before i
came but they said it i couldn't go in
it no i'm not sort of a health risk i
get that yeah that'll just shine
straight through you sun and tan down
the road he'll come out looking like mr
burns in the field it's true
i bring you love all right
so last week former vice president joe
biden uh accidentally which is always uh
always instills confidence in the
commander of the free world former uh
half
ish kamala harris
came with a usa strategy regarding the
ukraine
i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etcetera did he
say minor occursion my i mean yes
incursion
but it didn't sound like you said
incursion no no i give him a pass i just
try to assume what he's saying right
based on what i hear yeah brain kind of
fills it in so you have to have your
little little little orphan biden
decoder pen rule pretty much i think he
meant to say insurrection yeah i think
he would say insertion erection yes yeah
yeah well erection he was just asking
for one huh i got one guys [ __ ]
one in a long time stat huh
see i don't want this do you see alice
oh i got some code
i took so much of it
get out i slept late
let me be really clear here because
there's going to be a back and forth on
this discussion yeah we are not holding
water for putin i think putin's a dick
which is what dave was out protesting
apparently i was four in the morning
that's right um and uh this is my view
on russia i tend to line up with uh with
patton certainly as it related to world
war ii and after world war ii pre uh
yeah a little bit different boy sharing
this name that is a that is a problem
yeah i hope when you google it it
certainly shows up general patton before
patent
we should check i certainly should hope
that if i search patent it doesn't show
me oswald's king of king of queen
credits
i [ __ ] it does
so patton said uh near the end of world
war ii he said the difficulty in
understanding the russian is that we do
not take cognizance of the fact that he
is not a european but an asiatic and
therefore thinks deviously that sounds
bad it does sound bad we can no more
understand a russian than a uh china man
which is what he said back then or a
japanese and from what i have seen of
them i have no particular desire to
understand them except to ascertain how
much lead or iron it takes to kill them
wow in addition to his other asiatic
characteristics the russian has no
regard for human life and is all about
and is an all-out son of a [ __ ]
barbarian and chronic drunk
we fought the wrong enemy though that
may not be necessarily confirmed but
it's fun to include berlin gave me the
blues we have destroyed what could have
been a good race and we are about to
replace them with mongolian savages and
all of europe will be communist now to
be clear people tried to say that he was
a nazi sympathizer that's not what
patton was what patton was saying is
that there was a threat from russia and
that these were not people who basically
wanted to assimilate into western
civilization whatsoever and of course
there are alliances that you have at
certain points in time a lot of the time
people go why do we side with the
russians well keep in mind with the
russians they initially sided with the
germans in world war ii they were
buddies killed the germans attacked them
and then you know the germans uh killed
any well i don't know how if you take
the total number of killed but you know
holocaust is about six million and of
course you have millions other who were
killed in the battles with russia you're
talking about anywhere from 50 to 100
million people who are killed mostly
their own yeah just in world war ii
right like if we loop in war one to this
and the revolution it gets really high
right now that being said there are a
few and and uh gingersnap you were
writing this out so you were also making
this argument that uh the united states
sort of created the russia ukraine
scandal right and this isn't to say that
we could guarantee without the united
states
yeah the microphone is gonna have to
talk
into straight into the front of it right
there all right i'll try my best
it's not to say that uh he's south
korean he's directionally challenged
it's not just he's trying to get him to
use his blinkers
pick me up yeah okay no go okay
i wish i would have missed that joke
i did
i don't think i have any ambien but i
think i'm gonna have some lunesta in the
back as long as you don't mind the uh
the lcd uh lsd uh butterflies
so anyway ambient i mean gerald sang me
to sleep yes
the argument that myself and the other
writers are trying to make is not that
russia is this great country that should
be revered and putin is this bastion of
conservatism it is that
the steps that the united states have
made since the end of the cold war have
led us to what would always be this
outcome right okay and that is where we
lined up with kind of the map we put
together and the facts that we want to
discuss today and i know there's some
disagreements with the particulars of
those but i think don't be diplomatic
you guys were being dicks to each other
that's okay well i was winning the
argument that's all there was hey don't
don't taint the jury pool
and by the way you guys comment below
people who are watching on youtube
comment
where you line up right now should the
united states get involved and protect
the ukraine at all should they be
sending them aid or should we be
completely removing ourselves do you
think this is a case where
non-interventionism makes more sense uh
many people watching may not ha have
actually known anything about the
ukraine until of course uh vladimir
putin invaded crimea
and i say how does that work misleading
statement that russia outsmarted
president obama
other countries have said that the
reason why russia was kicked out was
very clearly because they annexed crimea
why keep repeating what some people
would see as a clear lie well it was
annexed during president i know you like
president obama but it was annexed
during the presidential flight if it was
annexed during my term i'd say sorry
folks
i made a mistake
sorry folks
president obama
was helping ukraine
crimea was annexed during his
term
president obama was pure and simply
outsmarted they took crimea during his
term that was not a good thing it could
have been stopped could have been
stopped the way a lot of you probably
assumed that uh and of course they've
been doctored propaganda exists a lot of
you probably assumed that
putin fired the first shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was for the nerds and i don't like
it so but
it made a point the russia ukraine
crisis started long before this and and
uh gingersnap you were explaining and
you and jail can kind of explain history
after the cold war right the united
states didn't really face any global
opposition right
so that that was a really good way like
so we didn't face any opposition but
what we were trying to do and i'll make
my point let him make his i'm not going
to make his point for him just i'll just
use the i'll just i'll just foreshadow
it's uh liberal hegemony that's the word
that we'll use
yeah i'm not really sure what it is
like liberal
so my point is that after
after world war ii we had a very
aggressive russian state that was
basically taking over part of europe so
that they could build kind of this
buffer between europe and themselves
right so i definitely understand that
but it was not just about russia it was
about the spread of communism as well
russia has done
nefarious things all throughout history
right so this this has played out over
and over again going back into the late
1800s russia in world war one fought
against germany and lost they were
trying to make sure that they could hold
on to ukraine they were trying to make
sure turkey didn't come in on the wrong
side so that they could get their ships
out into the mediterranean this has been
kind of the place that we've had to
fight over for a long time and so when
the league of nations was formed when we
formed nato when we formed the united
nations all of these steps were taken to
make sure this kind of conflict didn't
happen again or if it did that russia
faced a foe that could defend itself
interesting they didn't want turkey to
be on the wrong side hey look every time
you look to your yeah i was gonna say
look at any side of you that's the wrong
side that's where turkey is you tend to
pick always always right and i i get
that russia gets pissed off about these
things but it's not like these things
came out of nowhere right right we had
to do something to deter this and the
spread of communism was a very very real
threat right especially when spain and
franco's administration was communist
and you think he's stupid well i don't
disagree i don't try to pick a fight
look at him yeah what did you say about
his mom oh jeez lovely nice life
is a lovely lady yes lovely woman
but i i don't disagree with that
statement but that's like making the
argument that well
we shouldn't have allied with china then
and we why are we allying against them
now well they're two different countries
russia isn't the soviet union they don't
they're trying to be they don't but
communism is no longer really a factor
that we need to keep it it did fail but
have you been to stanford
no no no you asked people
that's a great point the third of
communism is greater from our
universities than it is from moscow we
should occupy them then yeah i think so
the the argument that's made here is
that we're looking at a different russia
after the end of the cold war so what we
decided to do after the cold war and we
brought it up earlier was called this
thing called liberal hegemony which is
basically that the united states feels
since they're not challenged by another
superpower there is nobody to rival them
that they can spread democracy across
the world and by doing this it'll make
peaceful relations between everybody and
no country has to worry about power
relationships anymore and that is the
mistake
i think our foreign policy experts made
that kind of led us to where we are now
okay so i would agree with that in maybe
the middle east right so with iran
propping up the shah we basically set
the stage for the ayatollah to come in
and there is no stabilizing the middle
east okay the middle east is the world's
bosu ball there's no way you are ever
going to guess and it's a balance board
and it's a rigged balance board well
yeah 130 there god doesn't even want it
there yes
and i agree with that in afghanistan
right afghanistan is known as the
graveyard of empires because every
empire that has tried to come in and
take over a people that should be take
over a bull has failed right the united
states included we weren't really trying
to take over we were just trying to
eliminate a threat so i get that you
can't just go and plant democracy in
every place that you would like to yeah
and i also get that not every time that
we've tried to plant democracy was it
with altruistic intentions we we had
power intentions we had motivations that
were maybe outside of that but at the
same time that again to use your point
those countries and the problems we had
there are not the same as making sure
that russia right doesn't go on well and
i think there's an important
differential differentiation to make and
this is what i would say is i only have
an interest in intervening if it
directly relates to our national
security interests yeah i don't i don't
believe we should spread democracy
spread because a lot of nations simply
don't want to share our values that does
not work that's what that's that is what
ultimately creates destabilization
however when we're talking about like
china and taiwan right we're talking
about something that would actually be a
security threat not only to all of asia
but the rest of the world once taiwan
goes you're talking about them getting
really in close proximity to japan
you're talking about circuit boards
you're talking about all kinds of well
yeah uh um hardware that is important to
the rest of the world with taiwan you're
talking about a real problem with china
and taiwan yeah i think with russia it's
one of those issues where it's it's a
little bit tough because you know
there's still you're still talking about
people who are largely like they have a
life expectancy of 54 because they all
die of cirrhosis and they poop in the
woods it's forced labor too that really
cuts down on the uh it does
it does it makes them very strong though
with their hands they can dig without
shovels yeah they can kill pedophiles
and get off scot-free so right the last
thing i'd magically do
not the last thing this is just
beginning sir you're not going anywhere
just before we move on i kind of want to
stress the two points the main points
that we're trying to make here is first
yes there is time for the united states
to intervene when should that be is a
discussion but right now the world we
live in russia is not the place to do so
when we have a much greater threat and
to who's that greater threat china china
and to
try to intervene
substantially in eastern europe would
also substantially decrease resources
that should be available for east asia
second off you just said nuke china wow
it's not out of the question
macarthur wasn't
he was a yeah
he's like i just don't think we should
spread democracy i don't believe in
liberal hegemony but uh yeah i'm let's
drop the uh let's drop the a-bomb drop
that effort twice let's do it right in
shanghai
at noon
shanghai is nice beijing is where you'd
want to go first just because the movie
i liked that one yeah referencing the
film yeah
thank you owen yeah i love jackie chan
movies who doesn't fantastic i think we
can all at least agree on okay that was
your one category that's the first point
and the second one is that
like putin or hate him he is acting
completely rationally as any leader
should in his position as a crazy
power-hungry psychopath yes he is acting
like a crazy power-hungry psychopath as
a realist as a realist right right yeah
i just want to make sure we say he's
operating in that world and for somebody
in that world sure he's operating like
he should well you know listen their
people have good sides and bad sides i
mean gacy could paint
he could hitler could paint yep
i have a gay c and a hitler do you yeah
they're great you know what i just i
find uh casey's work is just far too
interpretive it is well it's it's almost
self-important happening yeah a lot of a
lot of clowns and balloons and such and
i'm like why aren't i murdering anybody
potentially when when lame was talking
about uh putin i think what he's saying
is just like in the university system we
don't want communism in our university
system i think he's saying putin didn't
want that in russia either well what
putin doesn't want is anything that
disagrees with putin so let's not let's
not muddy those there's a difference
it's not like putin wants freedom for
his people and he wants a strong willed
people who understand what liberties are
he wants to arrest and jail indefinitely
you know a band like [ __ ] riot and
that's an important difference to see
that rage against the machine
i mean look if i personally could
probably write down top five things that
would bring a smile to my face tom
morello behind bars and a gulag would be
at the top of that list but you can't do
it yeah
so uh you know that lane and gerald are
smarter than me so i'm going to say
you're both right yes they're both
they're both right they can both be
right because in the world of
geopolitics nobody's right now after the
cold war i think we have a clip here
united states presidents they all
followed this idea of liberal hegemony
um
all of them really republican democrat
up until
one of these things is not like the
other one of these things just does it
payload donald trump they go out and
they make a gas steel
oil and gas from russia where they pay
billions and billions of dollars
to russia okay
so
they want to protect against russia yet
they pay billions of dollars to russia
and we're the schmucks that are paid for
the whole thing
so then
is projected to be paid by those nato
nations but it's not enough
do they ever tell you that no
no
by the way i love how donald trump just
puts a tone on something he doesn't like
it could be anything in other words it
could be he could sit you just because
you have russia it could be the same
thing because you have china
because you have jeb
low energy russia low energy hooted
low energy jeb he knows that honestly
saying it in a way that i don't like
that'd be a great pitch man now um as
part of the uh this agenda to the united
states they sought to westernize uh
eastern europe in a lot of ways um do we
have those numbers by the way uh in the
show map somewhere can someone get me
those numbers of what we were paying in
the nato we talked about this a long
time ago yeah i want to say that uh the
promise was a certain percentage of gdp
it was either two or three percent if
i'm not mistaken and the united states
was way above that and the next closest
nation was i don't know at some point
maybe it was poland when they were added
it was like 1.7 percent but a lot of
nations were
paying less than one percent right that
was the big problem that donald trump
had right was not paying their fair
share which he thought the democrats
loved the fair share argument it's
different from the u.n which is entirely
useless well of course i don't think we
should be in the u.n at all nato served
a purpose just to be clear however nato
has definitely become um
a political arm in a lot of ways well
yeah they probably outlived their
usefulness a little bit so and this goes
to um russia wanted uh nato to actually
remain intact to pacify unified germany
okay let's go back to this historically
and you can actually explain some of
this uh lane um germany is still
actually labeled an enemy of the state
of the un along with japan and italy
right for good reason right so after the
italy
they still mussolini i know but he was
just kind of like he was an ass but he's
kind of cute they're kind of like now
they're like can we just make our pasta
and wine from tuscany have you seen
tuscany it's beautiful we don't need a
fight yeah exactly oh noah five actually
there's there's nothing they can do
it'll well they haven't won a war in
modern history
that's true i've never seen tuscany have
you ever under the tuscan sun
oh my god diane lane diane lane always
looked like an attractive 40 year old
woman even when she was 20 but then when
she's like a 45 year old it's like she
just looks good now yeah yes she does
she grew into that body it's sort of
like the photo negative of clint howard
who just always looked horrifying we had
it but then you're like well he's at the
age where he should look horrifying
you're like that was the case when he
was 20.
i went to high school with a girl who
looked like a mom she had a mom haircut
and we called her the milf because she
looked 45 yeah and i saw her not no i'm
not and i saw her too long ago and i was
like wow you look just like you did in
high school there you go through into
the the diane lane who's laughing now
yeah everybody
that's not true so they're still labeled
an enemy of the state
along with japan and italy uh but here's
the thing though and i know we'll we'll
we'll find that funny now but who can
blame the u.n when i mean germany's
chief export it's a lot of you don't
know it's still this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh germans love david they do love david
hasselhoff
celebrate i don't know why
it's like he's like that's his voice
that's that's not his voice in the end
guys it's also weird that they decided
to pick and they were you know the
cafeteria baywatch viewers if you like
baywatch you take all of it in all its
splendor but instead and you chose david
hasn't he shows the david hasselhoff
yeah also is a former drunk never ate a
cheeseburger off a bathroom floor no
that's a special kind of problem
i will say this he did have his daughter
record him so that he could see it later
so that he could change and he did
change as opposed to hunter biden who
had his daughter record him so he could
get her in on the film and smoke some
parm so the point is as bad as we think
that is it's nothing compared to the
biden clan and it was a really good idea
having her record him because it didn't
haunt him at all no well
so sorry explain this so sort of because
nato russia pro-nato initially right uh
uh gingersnap but that was a big problem
they were pro-nato yeah so at the end of
the soviet union the beginning of the
russian federation they were very
pro-nato in the sense that they wanted
it to maintain where it was because they
saw it as a as a the buffer the whole
buffer thing i was talking about like
this seat between you and your guy at
the movie theater yeah well they saw it
as a way to pacify germany because
what's happened the last time that
germany had been unified well they tried
to invade russia and before that they
tried to invade russia before that they
did invade right nato will be like
urinal that i have between medic and
other men
yes
i don't want years with ki when russia
use urinal i use fire urinal in corner
not far urinal just one space ideal
urinal is in corner because even if we
want space apart there still is but
there's all this dick looking space but
if i aim in corner that thick backslash
no more backsplash and there is no dick
looking space i urinate in corner but to
intimidate i slowly move towards you
it's true until i share and then
eventually i rub earlobe and tell you
you're going to die today no no that is
my this short fight was won by me yes
okay so so continue here lane and gerald
you guys can just go ahead because you
hate each other we don't hate each other
yes you do so so they were trying to
keep the buffer initially with nato what
so what's the problem now with nato the
problem that now and the problem that
russia saw then and the problem even our
soviet experts saw then like
george cannon you know
george can he wrote the long telegram he
was kind of the architect of the soviet
containment policy director architecture
i know that worked so he even said as
much and i think we have the quote in
here somewhere that basically he said
expand this was in 97 i said expanding
nato would be the most fateful error of
american policy in the post-cold war era
such a decision may be expected to impel
russian foreign policy in directions
decidedly not to our liking so the
argument you're making now is that nato
russia understood nato but then because
of nato's expansion and also how they
and where they expanded yes yeah it
forced russia to say all right now we're
going to have to act aggressively right
and you can imagine this from their
perspective and again this isn't to say
russia is a great country vladimir putin
is a great guy it's not the opposite of
a reporter i get it russia's a crap hole
and he's kgb right but if you're looking
yes but if you're looking at this from
a rationalist perspective if you put
yourself in his shoes of the leader of a
country and your greatest adversary for
the last hundred years or whatever yet
70 years all of a sudden has the ability
to stage troops right next door right
you would see that as a threat so even
if we don't want him to expand we can
understand
bill clinton the nato expansion and
added uh who did it added poland hungary
and uh
and then in 2004 nato added seven more
eastern european countries so i get it
right there's a lot of stuff going on
there and then obviously we get to
barack obama's tenure in 2008 nato
endorsed the addition of of
ukraine and georgia oh we have a clip so
i get it
i will continue to make america's
position clear
we support map for ukraine and georgia
helping ukraine move toward nato
membership is in the interest of every
member in the alliance
and will help advance security and
freedom in this region and around the
world
did george w bush just say he supports
maps for ukraine i believe that's a
minor attracted person no
dave oh geez he came in late dave in
this context actually means membership
action plan yeah okay well different
arrows just well cheryl's just trying to
justify his sick fetishes but the truth
is i and i hate to point it out this is
also because george w bush did his prep
by watching dora that's right
[Music]
i tell you one thing not a terrorist
don't get me started on the on the
compass he's not here to take freedom
he's map
is it weird if i eat chicken wings well
i do my state of the union so um
all this angered uh russia and putin
responded uh the emergence of a powerful
military bloc at our borders will be
seen as direct threat to russian
security and uh this is of course you
know russia went to war with georgia but
here's the thing not the state not
georgia not the just in case no the
country no the state was that was a long
dead they no longer filmed in georgia
because of their voter id laws yes but
here's the thing
that's probably true that is true
my point is this do you so do you think
that uh russia was
gingersnap justified and going into
georgia i mean i guess my question is
yeah the united states meddled okay
post-cold war i think a big part of this
is
um
you look between world war ii and the
cold war americans don't have the
stomach to win a war anymore no you need
to go in break stuff convert people and
leave that's the truth that's what a war
has always been afghanistan should have
been making it look like the uh the ice
castle and then walking out that's how
many bombs we should have dropped and
instead you go in you try and work with
people you try and create alliances and
then there are insurgencies and it just
destabilizes it that's not what war used
to be yeah because we didn't have sort
of these these global uh you know
interconnected governments and that's a
problem now yeah they would go in and
actually install their own leaders they
would take part of the people and
disperse them around the kingdom so that
nobody would be associated with just
that country to i don't know maybe take
up arms against them again right i think
we've forgotten history and that's i'll
make that point in just a second here
actually no i'll do it right now i think
history is the problem for a lot of
people dave you just got a history of
problems for dave
yeah but it's understanding history
right and so we've seen russia so your
your i guess point is that look he he is
a power hungry psychopath but he's doing
what we expect him to do in this
situation and us going into these places
is causing it all right i will make a
counterpoint to that and say that russia
has always done stuff like this
after
the after
after world war ii they actually started
kind of pushing communism into places
first i think czechoslovakia was one of
the first places in the late 1940s and
then we had the outbreak of the korean
war which was again communism kind of
encroaching on freedom you were in south
korea you could be singing they wouldn't
have let you in in the first place my
friend if the north had won backed by
communist china and russia right so they
were pushing before and so i wouldn't
let you in if i was their bouncer the
united states and its allies had to do
something right so you've got a bully
if you leave the bully alone what does
the bully tend to do so we've heard john
bolton's point what do you uh what's
your counterpoint there okay so we keep
looking at warhawk yeah no we keep
looking at
russia like it's the soviet union and
geopolit the geopolitical situation is
exactly the same as it wasn't in world
war ii if we're going to refer to that
who were we we are going to refer what
do you mean why wouldn't we refer to
that okay so we are let's refer to it
it's
it's one of the top two biggest wars
okay who who were our allies in world
war ii
world war ii i mean we had france
germany
france well the main guys were france uk
the uk yeah it's canada
uh
further east you want me to go east of
ukraine because it didn't russia part of
that now do you want me to go to russia
the chinese the chinese were one of our
hold on hold on hold on can i sort of no
i think sort of yeah do you know what
they did
the chinese basically just got in the
way of bullets
they didn't they weren't like an
allies before them canada because they
actually went in d-day and stormed the
beach oh my god though it's so
embarrassing let me just tell you this
they did you know when we started so the
united states was uh it was omaha yeah
what was it omaha which ones uh there
was omaha uh gold swords
so juno was the canada one yeah they
walked i guess because
yeah so if you watch the juno beach
there's actual footage of the juno beach
them go and by the way thank you canada
i forgot the last we do we really
appreciate it but juno uh was a canadian
beach and we were watching it in class
and so i of course you know saving
private ryan have been out so i'm
expecting you know going
and instead you just see them kind of
like jog with their packs into the mist
they make it all the way totally fine no
one goes down because like what should
we do about the canadians
that's them
it doesn't matter all their horses are
drowning
you're supposed to swim not when you're
on's an [ __ ]
joke's on you
say things this is like white fang in
real life yeah so all right so china
stupid is this is not bacon so the point
is that different geopolitical times we
ally with different nations so we hit
that so right now
we are not allying with china for
specific reasons and they don't need to
be stated it's very clear right so we
need to look at the situation is it
exists today and so what benefit does
the united states get from antagonizing
russia when we could use them
strategically just like we used china
civil the soviet union during the cold
war okay fair point right hot benefit do
you think he asked and this i mean what
who who have you with whom
shall we align ourselves
why are you pronouncing that
[Applause]
so here's the thing do you do you think
that russia would want that we have been
like you said for 70 plus years the
greatest you know kind of
i guess holder against russia somebody
that's going to keep russia from
becoming what they really want to do is
dominate all of europe right because
they showed that they show do you think
for a second that they're going to just
walk back to the lines and say okay good
the united states is not the threat that
we thought they were
they're playing nice with us we're good
to go do you think that'll happen no
absolutely not but there's there is a
line that has to be drawn but our line
can't be drawn across the entire globe
it's not it's drawn at the states that
you used to occupy that you left and
that now you are unilaterally going back
to and saying hey you're not a country
anymore you're back to being part of us
the reason that they want ukraine it is
yelling he's not a woman listen
i'm trying to make my point wait till he
sees the castle he made wait until i use
all caps dave okay you're about to see
it ukraine has been central to the
problem for a very long time right by
taking crimea they are making sure that
their black sea fleet can get out to the
mediterranean that's easy to see it's
easy but they had a naval base there
before they did have a naval base there
before but if we are strengthening
ukraine and their ability to fight don't
you think that naval base starts well
hold on let's go back to the ukraine a
little bit so and then we want to
continue down there all right because
the united states spent billions of
dollars halfway through my point
billions of dollars trying to influence
ukraine and oppose what some people
would say are lawfully elected
politicians so the united states
invested five billion dollars in ukraine
from 91 to 2013. the u.s also uh funded
the national endowment for democracy
which helped fund opposition to
ukraine's
democratically elected ish free and fair
election president
not quite as secure as 2020 yeah number
two same territory really close you got
80 million also just so uh you guys can
know to understand sort of a motivation
here and who's lining up where from 1990
to 2015 george soros's organization
international renaissance foundation i
just thought it was a fair with a bunch
of people in burlap they spent 181
million dollars to spread democracy to
the ukraine because soros loves him some
democracies are in the ethic uh here's
soros admitting is uh basically that on
cnn in 2014. first on ukraine one of the
things that many people recognized about
you was that you
during the revolutions of 1989 funded a
lot of dissident activity civil society
groups in eastern europe and poland the
czech republic
are you doing similar things in ukraine
well i set up a foundation in ukraine
before ukraine became independent of
russia
and the foundation has been
functioning ever since
and it played an important part in
events now do you think ukraine will be
able to assert a kind of independence
from russia
and an alignment
with the west not but not a specific
alignment as a nato but a kind of
orientation toward the west or will the
russians always stop them no
putin will try to destabilize
ukraine but the ukrainians
the large majority of ukrainians are
determined to be independent of of
russia it won't be easy because when you
need stabilization you need yet another
evil person who looks like a poddling
what is it with yeah but you got janet
yelling no look come on that's they
could be this is what happens
he's a billionaire you can't get eye
cream yes
retinol irritates it's just make my age
spot look worse i have so much baggage
from uh world war ii it starts to form
on the rise yes this actually is uh evil
trying to escape my face
so i stuff it back and reuse zipper yes
i make my first billion of gold fillings
yes yes i'm now russian when i unzip
skin suit i look like things from they
live now excuse me return to fraggle
rocks
this giant is always trying to catch me
all right i'm dozer okay so go you guys
go ahead and explain the history here a
little bit so people let's not get too
nerdy so people i don't know i know i
want people to follow so the catalyst
for the revolution right oh i don't
2013. correct right yes that's correct
so there was a thing called like the
medan revolution that's what they called
it in ukraine it was basically they
there was the president at the time who
was the one that was democratically as
much as you can be democratic say it
with air quotes democratically elected
mm-hmm most free and fair election ever
besides 2020. obviously
the same people george soros's groups
were funding against okay ended up
signing a economic deal with moscow that
was better than the one with the eu
and the economic and economic deal most
a lot of the people in
kiev were unhappy about this because
they did want closer relationships with
the eu right that's western ukraine
eastern ukraine's a very different story
either way there was a revolution he
ended up being ousted yeah
yeah right
that would be good do you both agree
that that's good or no you think it's
bad no he was ousted i don't know if it
was good or not but i know that we
definitely played a part in that
happening yes
almost like if maybe i don't know there
was a green movement for freedom in in
iran and we would play a role like yeah
we we think that you guys should
overthrow your oppressive government but
it wasn't for it wasn't
[Laughter]
this is not like a moral judgment on who
is right or who is wrong just who did
what based on the facts and what they
are but you have to look at some of the
motivations right so if somebody is
going to go in and say look this guy was
in office he started to get really
really cozy with the russians and
these things were not things that people
liked and they protest they had a
revolution they overthrew them it's like
okay well we helped something that was
already going on maybe if we started the
revolution maybe if everybody loved him
and we came in with a propaganda
campaign and said no no no he's a really
bad guy that'd be a different story
that's exactly what happened after he
got elected in 2010 that's when all the
money starts coming and that's when the
soros foundation there were already
people who disagreed with this guy yeah
what about the in 20 2015 this doesn't
matter 93 of uh
crimeans crimeans crimeans i said crimea
before then it got then i heard trump
saying crimea i don't know what it is
right right right
crimeans said they supported russia's
annexation that's 93 you can't get 93
percent of americans to support anything
not even that gay order on cnn well how
many i can just tell you they
when they're walking door to door to ask
hey do you support the russia's takeover
of crimea so these are answers correctly
these were surveys done by german and
american pollsters germans they make
another appearance of course i will
bring it back to what stephen said about
patton how he commented on the slavic
people or the asiatic people as some
people we can't trust well these are the
same people we're talking about now they
haven't changed and most of these people
still can't trust them
most of the people inc the ethnic
majority in crimea is russian the ethnic
ethnic majority in eastern ukraine is
russian so to say that
they are all about being part of the eu
and these european values well we know
according to what patton said that
doesn't coexist yeah but are we trying
to make it happen but does it mean that
russia can just take part of a sovereign
country because they want to well i
don't think i don't think that
gingersnap is saying that it's a good
thing that russia is taking part of a
sovereign country i think what what
gingersnap is saying is that
maybe it's not the united states job to
go in and do anything about it okay so
that was like emma do i have that right
that
pretty much okay so i will what do i
have wrong no
so yeah because pretty much leave some
room there what are you trying to say i
think we know that putin will though be
the one who's going to show his hand
when he eats oreos i'll say that much
to norrie hotel whether or not they
should have annexed korea or whether
they're not
sorry crimea or whether or not they
should have supported the separatists in
eastern ukraine
i'm not even arguing that i'm saying you
could not have expected them not to do
it based on the position they found
themselves in
russia didn't find my opinion is that
russia didn't find themselves in any
position russia
was an instigator from the very
beginning
and the response that we had to russia
was that we've got it they were eddie
haskelling it a little bit we've got to
curtail their spread of comm like we
faced this in several places around the
world russia wasn't just sitting back
after world war ii going everything's
hunky dory i guess we'll go back to our
lines they wanted to keep the eastern
bloc countries that was the iron curtain
they did that yes but something happened
in 1991 yes and now that country no
longer exists and that
that you that alliance doesn't exist
anymore i get that but the same people
who in 1991 experienced freedom for the
first time in generations
very quickly after that said we can't do
this we need a state-run agency again we
need people to take care of us free
enterprise needs to go away and people
like putin were all too willing to come
in and actually step down have the other
person that gets placed in that office
change the constitution essentially and
say that you can serve as dictator for
life and then he comes back in and he's
like i didn't do it it was that guy
russia's gone like that's that's what
they're doing right now it's cute when
was the first time that russia showed
aggression towards these former eastern
bloc states since after the cold
nineteen oh after the cold war you're
going to the cold war as the start of
this it was 1949. yeah why are you going
to the cold war
because it's russia now and not the
soviet union and we're in a much
different place
listen i understand that history doesn't
repeat itself but it often rhymes and
this rhymes a lot that's what we've seen
before out of russia in any state
whether yeah so
i
i agree russia historically is not a
good country they're not a good country
now okay right right i agree with that
but russia you just said bomb russia
right just for everybody listening the
red wings disagree
well the capital's got a lot of value
let's not talk about hockey people's
eyes will glaze over even further so no
they won't the the point i'm trying to
make is from 1991 to 2008 there was no
aggression at all from russia into the
former eastern bloc there was no
question at all gerald that's not true
in 2004 didn't they invade georgia in
2004 yeah what about 2004 that was 2008.
well they do in 2004 they did something
something about 2014 about 2008. the
2008 invasion of georgia was in direct
response to us offering them a place in
nato you gerald what'd he say so here
let me just play this out for you hey
stephen you've got a bully attacking you
and you can't defend yourself by the way
if that ever happens i'll take your side
and the bullet goes see you're an
instigator and i'm like no it's because
you're a bully that i have to say that
i'll defend this guy well if you
understand where we're coming from here
no no i understand let me okay let me
just try and laser in on this here okay
we're talking about your argument is
and i don't think it's ill-founded that
russia felt that they were in a position
where they had to
in other words their justifications
they're effectively responding right to
encroachment to basically what they
would see is an oppressive form of nato
that obviously has uh is is unfavorable
towards russia right okay
so that's why they're acting out let's
say that when we're talking about
ukraine here's my question if none of
that happened to be the case with nato
do we think that russia would be
straightening up and pl you know flying
right or do we think they would still be
doing this anyway i think they would
still be doing this whenever they could
get away with it i think that's a fair
assessment to a fair guess and i don't
think that your point shared are
unfounded
but
it had not happened until nato expansion
was offered to ukraine and georgia so
the
i don't know 17 years of evidence that
we have suggests that maybe they would
not have but now we know for sure
that they would and we did
so what okay and you guys can comment
below on who you agree with do you agree
with gingersnap or do you agree with
gerald or do you agree that uh we should
never talk about russia again
until they attack even people even our
audience members who are using vpns
right now in russia watching are like
who gives a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i am already drunk you said you talk
about
women on page five you have where are
the russian breasts behind the pay walls
i haven't seen this with my own eyes so
i can't confirm but they say like they
have russian news like that are topless
and then they'll have really i'm not
kidding they'll have somebody can look
this up they will also have in
newspapers i'll have like a nice girl on
like page five oh sorry yeah somebody
could look this up i just i just
basically sent you to look up porn my
apologies that was not the intent
that's a good thing nope yes sir no it's
not here's actually the one thing that i
will say uh in regards to i agree with
you and this is something that really
does actually concern no i agree with
ginger snap on one thing okay the idea
of liberal hegemony um yeah you know i
always said this before when barack
obama was president uh and there were
situations you know hamas and israel
really there was a while there but there
were a lot of rockets going on oh yeah i
was very concerned for the first time i
thought that the united states
might be on the wrong side of history
might align themselves with the wrong
people when you heard his rhetoric
toward israel i'm not talking about
whether we should intervene or not but
there's a big difference between saying
we shouldn't intervene at all we
shouldn't be funding any of these
nations in the middle east um and we
shouldn't have an alliance with saudi
arabia versus saying we should
selectively support you know palestine
or the people who rule palestine and i
will say this for the first time i
if you're going to let's say world war
ii or even before that if you're going
to talk about the united states
spreading its values throughout the
world this is something where really you
would be talking about places like
russia where people are placed in gulags
or if you're talking about even places
you know in africa where just we know
when we would send in missionaries when
we're teaching them about aids and not
just throwing contraceptives at them but
letting them know hey look abstinence is
also important you can't have sex with a
child to give your aids on down the line
we needed to actually establish cultural
norms now this is something they
believed and say there are there's a
superiority to this culture as a result
of judeo-christian values and so i think
we would all have been on board at one
point with the idea that all of these
countries would be better off
if they adopted american values not that
it's our job to force them to right
however yeah
i can say now for the first time if i'm
a country if i'm and this is not to say
that russia is a free country does not
say that putin is anything other than
basically a fascist asset okay that
being said it's a lot easier right now
if you're putin or any of these
countries to uh basically score at the
united states for interventionism go
look look you want this to be like
country where you have men beating women
in college athletics little boys being
taken away from father because not
taking puberty blockers look they have
abortion up until including after birth
run clip of ralph northam look they tell
their children to get fat and feel that
they should be proud and healthy i rest
my case with exhibit z lizzle eating a
pizza with ranch my point is it does
concern me that i i the values right now
yeah that we would export are not values
that i would want exported no no
unfortunately though she replaced the
cheese with it let's not go nuts that's
true yeah those are the kind of values
that should not be and those are the
kind of values that make me go yeah i
get why they hate it sometimes right
like sometimes it makes it
apparent but here's the thing yeah maybe
isis has a point we have learned
throughout history that we can't be
isolationists whether we want to or not
we are the world's greatest superpower
at this moment now that can change
historically those things change people
move up and down especially if you get
away from the values that made you the
superpower in the first place
but we are in this position so what do
we do well in the 1930s we said your
problem over there not our problem over
here and you know what followed the
greatest wartime period in the history
of the world that's the one with the
nazis correct uh
yes good right because everybody looks
at world war ii as 1939 and on and the
seeds for that were planted far far far
earlier right and that's why i say
history is rhyming you have the former
soviet union which is now russia they
are going back into places that used to
be a part of that soviet bloc people who
are militarily beaten down knowing that
they can't even hold they can't even
hold their own region if they get
attacked right they're not the
superpower that they were and that
greats at people that graded it hitler
and he used it to push back and say see
we're being kept down and we're not as
great as we once were and we can be
again so that's something you have to
keep an eye on if they invade ukraine
right now i'm not saying we send troops
but i think we have to understand that
this is not one of those silly things
that barack obama did there's a red line
for assad and assad goes boom steps
across the road
exactly
and gaddafi you can't do this gaddafi
does it his own people take him out
thank god they had the balls too because
we certainly didn't hillary clinton says
why should we have to talk about this
stuff anymore i get it i understand that
right but we do have to at certain
points in history go okay
if we don't stop him now if we don't do
something now this could spin out of
control because it has over and over and
that's what was talking about after
world war ii he was saying russia's
going to become a power that we really
should have uh squashed when we could
have yeah what are you okay go ahead uh
i i agree completely with all that i
just i win i think you have the players
wrong here oh who are the players you
think china's the player they are the
player so here's the thing
china can be controlled economically to
some degree whereas russia it's harder
to russia you say the nordstrom thing
and they're just gonna fight you right
with china we can be like hey you can't
bring in highway whatever that guy
pronounced the other day i went all of
our debt no oh i would say oh highway
all of it now i was thinking you mean
you mean the phones huawei
we have little to no economic leverage
over the chinese and they don't frankly
don't care very much
their economy is almost to pass ours as
far as gdp size goes rush is about 120th
the size of ours they're just they have
no they're not a real threat that they
were during the 1960s 1970s china is
that threat that our focus should be so
what would you have us do with the
ukraine right now good money and rubbish
i would go
listen this is not to say that because
we do have the 1994 agreement where we
made them give up nukes that said yes we
will defend you we do have that right so
our word we dug ourselves this whole so
we might have to do something i don't
know i don't want a century we dug
ourselves whole like pedophile in russia
who then stabbed himself in chest twice
eight times the 28th time that's how
pedophiles killed themselves in russia
shot himself eight times in the back in
the middle of the woods running his name
was cech set richovsky yes
friend of clinton's yes yes yes it makes
snow grave my point is and i think you
would probably agree with this is that
our trying to make the world a liberal
bastion is not going to happen it has
failed yeah and while we've been trying
to do that countries like russia and
china understand that realism power is
this thing that still governs
politics across the world so russia
understands that they don't like china
inherently they would
love in my opinion to form closer
relationships with us
at the u.s yes
against china yes only if it's the the
enemy of my enemy is my friend yes
that's but that's politics there's so
much i don't trust either them further
than i can throw them and i can throw a
chinese man much further than i consider
the average russian probably could yeah
right yeah
it was like 14 feet yeah
i think we even have a poll in here from
that they ran in moscow the moscow times
ran that's it like five out of six
russians are friendly towards the west
they don't have problems with this
there's no ideological rift that existed
during the cold war anymore well so it's
their leaders then and that's the
problem because okay maybe the people
aren't at our throat but their leaders
kind of are and i'm not saying again
like we're not in the cold war right now
we're not in the same position that
we've been in historically with russia
but i am much more afraid
of a 120th the size of our economy
russia that used to be a powerhouse and
they're trying to get back there and
they'll do whatever they have to so
ukraine was not just important for a
number of the other reasons that we've
talked about they were the bread basket
of the soviet union they fed most of the
soviet union which is why hitler went
there first to try to destabilize russia
and he almost succeeded and if he had
we'd be looking at a very different
world map right now so i don't look at
russia as a non-threat and i don't i'm
also not taking my off china i get that
they're a bigger threat we've talked
about taiwan on this show several times
i really don't like china and here's the
difference
well not the
dogs i don't really need lane's just
come out as a scorpion in my life but
we're talking about americanized
children did somebody threaten to nuke
george over the weekend
or
alabama
the college game gone wrong
oh it was normal
it was austin texas i love how when he
threatened to nuke the united states he
was like i'm gonna hit uh new york
chicago washington d.c and austin so
cool
i think we're all good look here's the
point this is one of those things where
you know i hate to use this where people
say everything is nuanced and the truth
is there's really not much nuance to uh
abortion as far as okay look you either
support it or you don't and you at least
draw lines to where life begins or it
doesn't there really isn't all that much
nuance to you either have the right to
speak freely or you don't okay so it
doesn't it doesn't need to be that long
of a back and forth conversation there
really isn't all that much nuance to the
second amendment you either have the
right to self-preservation
self-protection or you don't when we're
dealing with geopolitical issues however
that that really and that's almost i
hate the term geopolitical we're dealing
with international politics let's just
make it simple you're dealing with
international politics you're also
dealing with countries who don't act
within the kinds of rights that we know
and take for granted a lot of you for
example don't know that there really is
no other place on earth outside the
united states where you have the right
to speak freely free speech doesn't
exist doesn't exist in canada it doesn't
exist in the uk it doesn't exist in
australia not to mention the right to
keep and bear arms there are a lot of
rights that we have enshrined in our
constitution so when you're dealing with
international relations there is a
little bit more nuance because and i
don't want to say nuance there is there
is more that needs to be taken into
consideration when it comes time to pull
the trigger in other words here when you
say all right look you can't do this
this is going to the supreme court it
needs to be swatted down all right look
this is an issue where it's black and
white we understand okay the states have
voted when you're dealing with do we
intervene
what do we do here with the uk how much
of it is the united states fault how
much is
you know the international community
meddling how much is it their fault
what can the united states do at this
point how much does it relate to a
national security issue i think we can
agree on this china taiwan we all here
in the studio have a red line that needs
to absolutely be stopped because not
only is china a key player not only does
china hate the united states but but
taiwan if taiwan goes that would be a
huge deal for international security
period not just the usa with russia i
think gingersnap makes some valid points
i think that jail makes some valid
points i mentioned to hear you guys
comment below and you guys can also
after you comment uh and you know it's a
little bit dryer a little bit nerdier
but there's no way to address the russia
ukraine thing there's no other way to do
it aside from playing risk and acting it
out which maybe we'll do
we'll do and we'll just use uh we'll use
dave's ambien instead of figurines
i get to be i don't really take ambien
just to be clear i get to be the xanax i
can talk to xanax then both want people
to be like he's really no he hasn't
relapsed at all no no no no no no no no
of course ambien doesn't count uh and
smash the like button if you're watching
on youtube we have a lot to get to we do
the rest of this week including
wikipedia that's a huge video on
thursday and now we're going to go to
mug club and play finnigan knows all
which would never be permissible here on
youtube gingersnap thank you very much i
appreciate it you are articulate and
ladies who like redheads will be all
over themselves get out get out before
it gets creepy youtube piss off
bye